hello everyone my parents have been in
town which means that there is some news
that i was not able to catch up on and
not able to cover because i tried to
value family time they are now gone
devastatingly and i thought that i would
catch up on some of this stuff so i
wanted to read up on the xbox live
outages um but also the square enix
selling tomb raider
um which
just so nuts because the nft market
basically had this huge collapse right
around the same time
um but yeah they sold a bunch of ip
they're western ips specifically so not
you know final fantasy
which is the one everyone kept asking
about
uh to embrace a group which
we should be looking at they're growing
very very rapidly so
here's an article from
kotaku
a lot of ads a
oh my so many ads it's fine um square
enix selling terminator deus ex and
thief
god bless the good days of thief if you
haven't played old thief
give them a try very good games
um okay oh my god the embracer group a
planet swallowing mass video game
publishers that already includes the
likes of gearbox and thq nordic again
someone we should probably be looking at
tonight announced a deal to purchase a
number of storied studios and properties
from square enix let me just make this a
bit more full screen
um
while the purchase isn't final pretty
likely though this is just an agreement
to acquire them until everything is
signed off later in the year the
announcement press release says that if
approved it will be a usd 300 million
dollar deal
for 300 million embrace a group will get
a hold of the studio's crystal dynamics
idos montreal and square enix montreal
the latter of which will presumably be
in for a name change makes sense
numbering around 1 100 employees
worldwide which is a pretty big
acquisition but damn 300 million
seems like a steal uh the catalog of ips
owned and or worked on by those studios
including deus ex tomb raider thief
legacy of kane and the continued sales
and operation of the studio's more than
50 back catalog games
also of interest crystal dynamics is
actively working on several aaa projects
including the next mainline tomb raider
game that will deliver the next
generation storytelling and gameplay
experiences
aren't they also
if i'm remembering correctly they're the
studio that is also working on perfect
dark
i wonder if the
acquisition would shift any of that
food for thought
perhaps knowing that the first question
most folks would have following a day
like this would be so what's happening
with those series embraces press release
says
the acquisition brings a compelling
pipeline of new installments from
beloved franchises and original ips i'm
not going to do that the whole time
including a new tomb raiding game the
acquisition builds on embraces mission
of creating a leading independent global
gaming entertainment system gaming and
entertainment system hard to be
independent when you're the one owning
them all um embracer has been
particularly impressed by the studio's
rich portfolio of original ip housing
brands with proven global potential such
as tomb raider and deus ex as well as
demonstrating the ability to create aaa
games with large and growing fan bases
there are compelling opportunities to
organically grow the studios to maximize
their commercial opportunities
if you look at the other things that
embrace our own
again it's a lot
um surprisingly quite large and they do
have a lot of existing ip
i would like to dig in a little bit
further just personally onto
what embraces plans
are got revenue down here operating
income matters quite a profit net income
total assets 33 billion dollars worth of
assets they think or kr
total equity
owners laws wingers this is the best way
to figure out what a company wants in my
opinion so
um they were the original audit games
well that's what
lars started
and the new nordic games was then thq
whatever that's beside the point um
rebranding is embracing group that's it
okay so at the end of its fiscal quarter
th cuny acquired game outlet europe from
nordic games
and then in august 2019 they inquired a
investment company goodbye kansas game
invest hmm they have saber interactive
uh what's the swedish developed house
yes studios do deals included studios 65
employees an intellectual product
include excluding little nightmares i
wonder why who published that up and i'm
that's why
seven acquisitions in 2020 4a games new
world interactive saber interactive rare
earth games vamilla studios powwow
entertainment thq nordic deca games
basically the clutch media one's the
most surprising one to me it's a really
interesting choice
it's a lot of acquisitions i want to
know what lars is about
he is the co-founder and ceo of embracer
group
europe's biggest gaming company
he owns 28 of the company which is
listed on the stockholm stock exchange
in 2016. and bracelet has a catalog of
over 200 game franchises
operates 57 gaming studios and has over
5 500 employees across 40 countries
i would think
being that it is
uh publicly traded
the play is probably to get most of
these ips on mobile that would be my
guess they are trying to acquire
existing ip
get them on mobile
make money that would be my assumption
yeah i'm pretty
impressive dude um
that would be my guess so
it's also funny because the
square did talk about why
they were willing
to uh sell
here we go it so seems so funny like
just so unexpected
so why sell square enix's own press
release says the transaction will assist
the company in adapting to the changes
underway in the global business
environment by establishing a more
efficient
allocation of resources which will
enhance corporate value by accelerating
growth in the company's core businesses
in the digital entertainment domain in
addition the transaction enables the
launch of new businesses by moving
forward with investments fields
including blockchain ai
and the cloud
wild i do think that there are some very
interesting components of blockchain
gaming
nfts i don't think are one of them um
but i do think there is some interesting
potential in blockchain specifically
i've always been very interested in ai
cloud ties into that there's a very
interesting feature where potentially we
could have
cloud-based storytelling um that is run
by an ai that could that could i had a
recent podcast where i spoke to the
founder of arcane
um
about that potentially being a thing in
the future that just nobody's made yet i
don't imagine square are working on it
but this idea of
video games storytelling has to be
limited by what we can write and then
what we can program there is potentially
a world
where
we could have cloud-based ai uh getting
rid of some of those limitations in
terms of storytelling in terms of like
fully immersive sims
um i won't delve into that here because
it would be very complicated but it is
something i'm interested in that i could
see the blockchain tying into i don't
know that that's what square's doing but
then there was also yes this big nft
crash right after this happened
um
crypto market is just not having a great
time right now apparently rick ross
thinks he crashed the nft market
the nft market recently crashed with
sales dropping 92 earlier this week that
is a lot of percents people have been
talking all about the crash on social
media and one of them is rick ross who
thinks he may have something to do with
it rick ross took to his instagram story
with a message for fans stating he had
nothing to do with the nft market crash
due to his comments earlier this week
about investors proving they're making
money in the cryptocurrency space man i
just woke up and i heard the nft market
crash 92 percent
that is wild
um but
in any case
it did recently crash i believe the yeah
the boy
ap yacht club probably the most
recognizable
nfts at this point
uh had trouble uh ethereum
um the crypto market crash basically
happened so buying an entry level board
ape today cost 55 less than a mere 10
days ago as the nft market bleeds red
aside crypto prices
um many popular nft collections fell
sharply
mirrors the ongoing crash for crypto
prices with bitcoin and ethereum hitting
10 month lows today
so just an interesting time for square
to do that but that that's what they
said they want to get into blockchain
wouldn't have guessed it a very strange
pivot um would not have seen it coming
you do you um very weird
the upside is
if they weren't planning to continue to
develop those ip um in any meaningful
way if they weren't planning to do
anything with thief which they haven't
touched
in eight years i don't remember when the
four came out but it was it was a long
time ago let's check i was still in
australia i reviewed it so that's how i
know that i was still in australia
before
and a lot of people didn't like it um
damn 2015.
oh no no no it was 2014.
that's a while ago um
then we don't get in a konami situation
where people are annoyed at konami for
heading more into pachinko they own a
lot of gyms in japan it's very weird to
see konami labels on things that aren't
video game related
uh obviously
metal gear hasn't had anything since
survive which was not very well received
by the general public
um it's better to have square sell off
these ip and fast if they're planning to
pivot than to just keep them and do
nothing with them and then we end up
like every single hill fan in the world
with absolutely nothing so that's an
upside it's a very strange choice for
square um
hard to imagine that it's that it's
profitable that's the thing that keeps
getting me is like did it was that
really a good deal i don't mean
profitable like was that a smart
deal
um you try and find some analysis
it apparently closed the deal did close
digital trends here
this is an article called it's a good
deal for everyone which i
tend to agree with i'm not actually
upset about square doing this i'm i'm
surprised by it didn't see it coming but
i'm not upset
how we got here
it's just a bit of background on square
enix
oh man sleeping dogs
what a banger does this mean we get
another sleeping dogs i don't know if
they sold that
would be nice though okay so they say
the news is an app positive for everyone
in theory for the studios that were sold
to embrace a group it's a potential
blessing square enix wasn't doing them
any favors as western games were
becoming less of a priority i would
agree with that that's why they sold
them talented studios like crystal
dynamics have a better chance of
avoiding mismanagement under a group
like embrasa potentially so long as it's
committed to giving the studios its
attention it could also mean that
dormant ip's like legacy of kane could
make a return which opens up some
exciting possibilities for fans agree
with that
the square means the company can finally
focus that's something it desperately
needs to do after a string of
high-profile failures like babylon's
fall
and valen wonder world the publisher's
unruly release schedule should be more
manageable when it doesn't have to
balance marketing massive marvel
projects with the kind of surefire hits
that it knows it can knock out of the
park with its core audience globally i
think that's fair
on paper it's a win-win situation the
question is whether or not square enix
can actually settle down and there's
good reason to believe history could
repeat itself as part of the sale news
the company announced that it will use
the 300 million it's gaining to move
forward in its investments in blockchain
ai and the cloud that could be a
potential red flag for the next decade
for the company realistically i think
that's probably where a lot of them are
heading
of all those investments cloudtech is
the one that makes the most sense square
enix has
long been a successful player in the
mobile space and it has experimented
with cloud tech as part of that move
it's also brought a several of its games
to nintendo switch as cloud versions
recently
yeah i do think we can expect more and
more of that
blockchain presents a major question
mark though square enix has shown great
interest in the experimental tech as of
late but mainstream gaming companies
have yet to find success with it just
look at ubisoft which is currently
struggling to implement its nft service
courts again i do want to reiterate
blockchain crypto and nft
are not all the same thing
um
they are all different things
and don't have to tie into each other
they use each other
but they don't have to
it doesn't mean that they're getting
into nfts it well could but that would
be
very stupid in my opinion considering
how poorly it has been received every
single time every other company has done
that and they keep doing it
uh there's a chance granny's able to
make a breakthrough with the tech again
this doesn't necessarily mean enough
tease but not without facing a hostile
reaction from its valuable fan base i
would just get rid of that paragraph not
that i'm editing this
is square enix just going to pump money
into another dune business arm that
doesn't make a return on investment and
if it does is it really any better off
than it is now square enix finds itself
at a crucial crossroads
it's definitely strange unexpected i
don't think it's bad for fans i think
potentially good for fans and
i could see it being good for square to
have a little bit more direction
potentially um not that i'm unhappy with
the games that they've released lately i
don't know
so next i wanted to look into what
happened with xbox live
things go down
it happens
okay so i guess what happened was that
xbox live users were unable to access
digital games
even offline games
this is from gamerant
uh xbox users hoping to enjoy some
weekend gaming have been having a rough
day as several players are reporting
massive issues with xbox live what makes
this partial outage so problematic is
that the problems are not just impacting
online connectivity but preventing users
from accessing digital content in
general damn
that sucks
these xbox live issues started earlier
today with streaming apps such as
netflix and disney plus with the content
on these applications being inaccessible
for around four hours while this issue
was eventually resolved new problems
came out
came about shortly after due to unknown
causes user currently on users are
currently unable to purchase digital
gains from the xbox marketplace or start
up sessions through cloud gaming
however this is just the tip of the
iceberg wait okay what is the tip of the
iceberg not only are xbox users unable
to buy new games or use cloud gaming
services but they are also unable to
access their digital games
oh i hate this
even if players have a fully
have a digital game fully downloaded or
are attempting to load up an xbox game
pass title
that they have already played for hours
they may be unable to launch the game at
all it goes without saying there's a
massive issue through the at xbox
support twitter account
has confirmed the problems of being
investigated and that a fix is currently
in the works
damn
that sucks
uh
there was a brief period where xbox
support reported that problems were
solved the fix was only temporary just
three hours after the tweet was posted
saying that gamers could get back to
enjoying their weekend and playing their
favorite xbox titles
a post mentioned that the same problems
with launching and purchasing games had
come back around i wonder
what they think the cause was
microsoft investigating doesn't
necessarily have a ton of info here huh
oh there are issues today as well
this is the same article just in a
different place
wow okay
um that objectively sucks when you
bought something and you can't play it
that sucks that's real bad we don't like
that for anybody that's
i guess the idea of a digital license
that you've is that you've purchased it
you don't actually own it um i guess
that's part of it but that doesn't make
it okay and it terrifies me for the
future uh i could not be more certain
that video games are heading in a
direction of um
wanting to be only online and i've been
saying this for probably like five years
on this channel then i'm very concerned
about the future where all games have
ads in them where everything is free to
play but you have to watch an ad for
10 seconds a minute where a cutscene has
an ad in it
where you know how an hour and a week
there were those duracell billboards
um that but on crack
uh i think it was duracell or energizer
i don't remember obviously it didn't
work that well there was an actual brand
that paid for that i'm very very
concerned about that i think uh nba2k
already does that
but
especially with vr
um facebook makes all of its money in
advertising i have no doubt that
facebook is going to try to advertise
more heavily to me on oculus things that
are not just oculus sorry meta as it is
and i love my meta my meta quest
um but i don't want that and i'm i'm
very concerned about you know just how
much money there is in advertising
that's how
instagram twitter youtube
here we are
makes money uh and the fact that video
games are either making money from the
sales themselves
or just from
in-game items um is definitely not
enough for all these publicly traded
companies that want to be the most
profitable businesses in the world i
feel like
it's almost inevitable especially when
you know they see players
playing a game for 100 hours and only
spending 60 dollars they're like we need
to figure out a way to get more return
on every single person who's spending
all these hours here like the social
media apps do like facebook does with
all the advertising
it very much concerns me and i feel like
this is like an inevitability that
there's nothing that anyone
can even really do anything about at
this point
it's a real shame um
i don't think this is going anywhere i
think it's going to get worse it is
generally my take which obviously
absolutely sucks and i don't really know
what you could do about it um
buy physical games if you still can even
then technically you don't actually own
the game you still just
have a physical license to play it but a
little bit more longevity and donate to
video game conservation societies or
support them if you have the opportunity
to i think that would also help
a whole lot um
i've been worried about this future for
a long time let me tell you
doesn't feel great i still have my
nintendo 64 with my cartridges i will
hold on to them forever
um
that is the the two big things that i
really wanted to catch up on i know that
the way that i keep doing those these
are so rambly it's not like i'm giving
you news i'm just catching up on
something and like discussing it almost
like it's a stream even though it's not
they're not edited at all
uh so hopefully it's still easy to
follow and interesting it doesn't make
sense to like news report when i'm just
reading other people's articles to catch
up for my own purposes
so it is what it is i hope you all are
having a wonderful week and i will see
you next time